and I love like that you're so capable
and like you can be like you're hanging
with Snoop Dog
what's I was with Sno um last week and
he was just great he came to New York
and and he was just a well-dressed uh
Happy how did you guys come together
like cuz on my show on my show he came
in and cooked uh brownies and he oh I
bet made some other Stu I've made some
of those brownies and he's a he's a
lovely he's a lovely guy he's very smart
and good family man he is a fabulous
children fabulous grandchildren who saw
that though like that chemistry and
connection and just did some brilliant
producers you guys are really a team and
it's like I just wouldn't have seen your
dog's head is so
heavy my hand is falling asleep it feels
like 100
lb maybe he sleeps too
[Laughter]
much